[Music]
this morning our series i
on earth travels to africa to learn
about a creative approach to
plastic pollution that's showing up all
around the world it's called the great
pacific
garbage patch i like that in the pacific
ocean contains plastic waste
twice the size of texas that's big kenya
is one of the many countries
contributing to the pollution
hundreds of tons of plastic waste are
created every day in the capital nairobi
alone that's where deborah patter met
one young woman who's finding innovative
ways to tackle the problem
this is dundora about 30 acres of waste
that's the equivalent of 22 football
fields
despite a pioneering plastic ban kenya
is still
drowning in it and whilst most people
look at this and think it's an
insurmountable plastic mountain
one young woman saw a way to move that
mountain
there are days in kenya when you can
actually walk on water
this river is choking with so much
plastic
it's formed an unsinkable foundation a
disturbing health hazard for
everyone living here except this young
woman
so i get i get excited when i see waste
because i know that's
that's that's life for us
the fact that plastic does not sink is
precisely what intrigued material
scientist
in zambia matia i came across this
concept of using plastic to building box
in 2017 kenya outlawed single-use
plastic bags but it's still everywhere
clogging drains polluting rivers
contaminating animal feed
some of it ends up here in nairobi's
dundora landfill
which long reached its capacity and was
supposed to be closed down
20 years ago but every day waste pickers
trudge
through the rancid trash sifting for
plastic
plastic that matia had to figure out how
to turn
into bricks when you made your first
brick
how was that
that was the best day it took us about
nine months
just to make one break but one break
wasn't enough
no problem for a woman who likes to get
her hands
pretty much everything else dirty
so she built a machine to mass produce
the plastic bricks
first the waste is sorted to remove
rubble and metals
and then you're going to bake it exactly
figure if you know how to make cookies
this is just making cookies i could make
a brick are you saying
exactly the boiling mixture is molded
into building blocks as many as 2 000 a
day
35 cheaper than standard bricks and up
to seven
times stronger
pretty impressive yep it doesn't break
currently materials bricks are only used
for pathways in small households
but she wants to target big construction
companies next
compounding kenya's fight against
plastic is that two years ago
the u.s exported more than one billion
pounds of plastic waste
to 96 nations including kenya and
now wants to make the shipment of
plastic a condition
of a proposed trade deal
greenpeace activist amar suamanya
believes kenya
can barely manage its own waste let
alone
recycle americas it will be importing
more problems
if you are to allow this u.s kenya trade
deal to be used
as a way of damping plastic west on the
african continent
methier agrees countries should keep
their waste in their own backyards
and she intends to make good on what she
calls her
triple threat the more we recycle the
plastic
the more we produced affordable housing
problem the more we created more
employment for the youth
which means there's no time to get too
comfortable for cbs this morning
debra patter nairobi kenya
her enthusiasm is infectious in zombie i
like that
you need that when you're tackling a
problem that big incredible story no but
i like how debra set it up this would
look
insurmountable but you go to in zombie
who says you know she just gets excited
when she sees ways
and the difference that she's making if
you know how to make cookies i don't
know how to do that either